what makes a superhero a superhero it's
a hard question superheroes are people
who look out for others the fact that
they never give up always just in favor
of justice owning up to things that
you're afraid of
I think heroes can come in all shapes
and forms and it's really about owning
who you are standing up for what you
believe it today we re creating iconic
superhero moments we specifically are
going to be doing the famous upside down
kiss between Peter Parker and Mary Jane
honestly think it's one of the most
iconic superhero scenes of all time
probably one of most iconic kisses in
movie history today I'm going to be
recreating the iconic Superman photo
Superman has this very iconic classic
all-american look I'm excited to kind of
put a flip on it the image that we're
recreating today is Wolverine coming out
of the tank and she's so [ __ ] angry I
am so excited to do this piece because
as a trans person it is exactly how I
felt when I was able to be myself and
and to just be a hundred percent happy
in my own [ __ ] body and no one gets
to take that from me alright let's take
these photos one two three hand this up
not like this
so I'm getting ready to recreate this
Christopher Reeve Superman photos in
Superman 3 right after Superman fights
negative Superman
so we're filming this in a studio we're
going to put in the background after the
fact I'm wearing this suit and it has
this like beige skin so like it's like
built-in whiteness unfortunately get
used to the fact that the world is made
for white people and they don't often
consider that some people are not to
fade I feel like seeing Superman as a
black man is important to put that image
out there that anybody can be Superman
and Superman represents so many
different types of people 1 2 3
cool I really like that one
so we're having a very serious issue
right now it turns out that the opening
Spiderman cops when we got the mass is
attached to the body so we can't
actually do the lifting up that we need
for the photo yeah I think it works
right originally I thought that I was
actually gonna be upside down but I'm
going to get two separate images of us
kissing and then in Photoshop combine
them looks a lot more romantic in the
movie open your mouth a little bit yeah
I think Hollywood gets in this rut of
just churning out the same thing over
and over and over again something as
simple as changing the gender the
sexuality or the race of your character
can lead you to create different stories
and that's what people want now listen
we did it yeah all these movies are
about overcoming adversity it's about
being shunned by society and having to
be yourself regardless of what people
think and that is all what queer people
have to go through every single day one
two three yep my favorite superhero is
Wolverine as a trans person I wanted to
be something just as masculine as
Wolverine they shouldn't go lower than
with a little bit pastor hit I feel
pretty good I mean it's cool that these
are real metal claws I wasn't expecting
that
or hella heavy something that's really
important to me is every time that I see
Wolverine wearing his dog tags reminds
me of my struggles in the military as a
trans person it felt really cool seeing
the pictures afterwards I can't wait to
see what the end result is the shoot was
pretty freakin awesome
growing up I never thought I would do a
photo shoot of Wolverine it's like for
Halloween I always wanted that Wolverine
costume but I knew that I could never
have it if there was a lot more
diversity in superhero movies I would
have had a different childhood I think
that I wouldn't have struggled so much
with myself and my identity I'm keeping
these by the way it is really cool to be
wearing the suit and actually like
looking in the mirror and seeing myself
looking like spider-man if someone asked
me what makes spider-man spider-man
I think his intelligence I think his
courage his passion his love I don't
think his whiteness or his straightness
I don't think that's essential to who he
is
through talking about the idea of
Superman and kind of how he represents
this ideal all-american citizen and then
kind of relating that to how in today's
terms anyone can be that ideal citizen
who cares that he's a gay black man if
you're burning in a building Superman is
still gonna swoop in and save the day go
be a hero you don't have to wear a cape
sometimes you can just wear drag people
want to see themselves in movies they
want to see themselves as heroes so
let's make more of an effort to
represent more people in society so if a
little gay kid is growing up they can
see themselves represented and you know
they can aspire to be a hero themselves
[Music]